i would be remiss if i didn't mention
that i your humble host and the grave
threat to democracy
this according to the yale daily news
i will be going to yale
next week with senator cruz he and i are
going to be doing an episode of our
verdict podcast there live
and the yale daily news is encouraging
people not to attend according to this
opinion column from a freshman
at yale cruise and knowles are speaking
do not go the argument for why i am he
talks about how uh senator cruz is a
threat to democracy because he supported
trump and that's terrible but i'm a
threat to democracy apparently because
on on the anniversary of january 6th i
implored people to remember quote the
wise men who traveled a great distance
for their leader the true leader of us
all in defiance of an unjust government
i
i am not
saddened that someone is attacking me in
the yale daily news frankly that brings
me back to my youth it's been a solid
decade since that's happened and it
brings back happy memories i am upset
however that these supposedly educated
yalies don't get my excellent feast of
the epiphany joke that i told on january
6 about the wise men following their
true leader okay that's fine
[Music]
the student goes on let's be clear ted
cruz and michael knowles are guilty of
chipping away
at democracy
uh this is a terrible thing we should
care about democracy quote holding fast
to democracy starts at the local level
by refusing cruz and knowles and
audience
you have a method of intervention buy
tickets but don't attend
that's a genius move pay us not to do
anything you you're showing us hey by
the way if you send me just venmo
payments right now to michael knowles
that'll really show me that'll teach me
a lesson so and the more money you send
the more of a lesson i'm gonna learn
libs checks are fine too you can make
them out to cash that'll ouch that'll
hurt that'll sting
refuse to legitimize the event he writes
you signal to other yale students and to
the organization that invited them that
democracy is non-negotiable and that you
refuse to normalize the normal the
abnormal rather this is what good civic
action looks like there are many ways to
do this i'm only suggesting one yale is
an influential cultural political and
economic institution
yale this is my favorite line of the
whole piece
yale students flush with that great
power
hold the great responsibility to fight
for a more just and healthy democracy
democracy is non-negotiable don't don't
go see cruz and knowles
okay the reason i bring this up is not
merely to make fun of the
truly grandiose notions
that uh
18 year olds at yale have about their
place in society and their their role in
america it is our we must defend we 18
year old yale students are the great
bulwark against tyranny we must wield
our great power
of picking a few classes and going to
parties on the weekends we must wield
that power to
save democracy but it's because of this
word democracy
because they keep using that word
democracy and democracy does not mean
i think what they think it means
ted cruz whether you like him or not
is a united states senator he was
elected by the people of texas
he is
a
as representative of american democracy
as it gets
i do not hold elected office
i have a podcast i have a few podcasts
they're pretty popular podcasts
they get lots and lots hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of views sometimes
over a million views
i'm not saying that means that i am a
representative of
american democracy but it does mean that
there is an audience for this that's at
least some of the american people
want to hear what i have to say
and want to engage with the kind of
reporting that we're bringing here and
the kind of stories that we're that
we're discussing
that would be to a smaller degree
representative of american democracy and
i would suspect
that
senator cruz and i are a little more
representative of american democracy
than an 18 year old at yale
so why does the 18 year old at yale
think that he is the great defender of
democracy because he's not really
talking about
democracy when the libs use the word
democracy what they really mean is
liberalism
or progressivism or leftism or whatever
word you want to use but this explains
how
a united states senator speaking is
anti-democratic but
some extraordinarily
unrepresentative
elite
far left people are speakers for
democracy this explains how in 2016 when
the people vote for donald trump that's
an assault on democracy this explains
how in hungary when the people vote for
victor orban who is a conservative
leader there that's all reported
everywhere in the west as an assault on
democracy because it has nothing to do
with democracy and it has everything to
do
with liberalism and i think it has
everything to do with the liberal and
ultimately then progressive view of the
world which is that
there is a clear ending point for
history there is a cl there is a clear
political end that we are going to the
arc of history is long but it bends
toward justice and by justice the libs
mean their political program
and it this is good for everybody and we
should all know it and so any time that
an election doesn't go the way that
liberals want it to
by definition that election was
illegitimate this is why the libs don't
respect the results of the 2016 election
this kid at yale has a problem with
senator cruz raising questions about the
2020 election which was by far the most
corrupt election in the last 100 years
at the presidential level this is an
election where they changed all the
rules right beforehand and where in some
states they held the election in
violation of the state constitution like
in pennsylvania
this is an election where there are lots
and lots of questions
and yet if you raise questions about
that election you're a threat to
democracy if you raise questions about
the 2016 election which was a perfectly
ordinary election which was not
conducted during a global pandemic with
widespread mail-in ballots where the
worst thing they could claim occurred in
2016 is that the russians spent a
hundred grand on facebook ads the daily
wire spends that on facebook ads in what
like two hours that's nothing compared
to what you would see
in terms of an actual
interfering campaign in an election
and yet they say that's illegitimate
it's only a legitimate because the
conservative won
and i can't wait i look the event the
this advice isn't really all that wise
in the yale daily news because the event
that we i've got with senator cruz sold
out within about two seconds so
it's already sold out but i would
encourage people to stand in the waiting
line
we're going to get out there we're going
to spread some conservative views to a
campus that has gone extremely left and
it's going to be a great deal of fun
this is this is where the fight is at
this is why what you're seeing in
virginia in florida even in south dakota
now the political fight to stop the
radical left is focusing on the schools
that's where it should be the schools
the classrooms are a crystal ball to
show you what your country is going to
look like in 20 years did you like that
clip i'm glad even if you didn't like
that clip subscribe ring that bell get
the notifications also head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts sign up for the michael knowles
show leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]